[Music]
all
is
so this this one
you where I do things is I'm going to
fade
somehow so you have a couple Fades right
you can move your body
back you can turn
con you can do it uh in but your fade is
a little is more in the
test I can't stay here and stop
here
okay
turn right if I'm going to do going
forward there's a fade right
there and when you do this fade you he
has to go one way you have to go the
other
so your angle
deflection is this way to the right your
angle deviation is to the
left okay so even when you 10 con see
I'm on the other side
okay no movement I bought him
here I stayed where I was then I
go it's almost all your face you're
going to have that elbow
in don't go
here I won't
hear
[Music]
it's not going to be enough that you
just keep him there and you tell
me
you're on a you're on a different spiral
than he is can you see that I don't know
let's try he's going around
me you see he's nowhere near me when I
enter we're on different spirals he's
going that way when I enter is say same
thing here small he's going that
way and I'm going this way
here we're just passing each other he
can pop
me he doesn't have to block me he can
weave and hit me you
see so no not
enough change his
movement elbow in
boom put him on a different spot boom
[Music]
and that starts with the elbow
in elbow in
boom
no all right try it
again all right so I'll simplify my
techniques there I get to here here's
where we're looking
okay don't get GRE to start to pull your
elbow down you're going to ground that
foot and you're going to be on his power
line I can't pull that hand
down he has to keep going you
see and that's why we do the fingers
down in the I so Bo
boom okay and now I start working this
thumb like a song
I'll do it
incorrectly and I just go
here not going to get there you have to
throw him
forward fingers
down forward he goes this hand comes
under my
Center that's what does the
cut boom
whom to here and that's what
moves oh throw him bring it under your
Center that's where your weight goes on
that this would be
incorrect here here here
incorrect very much like you put your
weight under your hand here now you put
your weight over your hand
here so careful you're not
going doing this
Stu get him off his foot put that under
your
hand off his foot under your
hand
off
[Music]
under off
under
okay your thing hold under you
that's when my foot moves when this gets
under me that's when my foot
[Music]
moves whatever version you use to get
him on the under
spiral
M that's one my foot
move
so let me standardize it a
little notice that my hands work
together
boom don't get here and then expect that
hand to do
something
[Music]
so once you reaching for the
head
[Music]
and your hand is under you this foot
goes
behind now you're in that
spot doesn't go
first goes with the
hand
[Music]
let's slow it down
elbow get him going on a different
spiral Integrity here you see we're he's
going that way I'm going this way but
we're not in front of each other this is
integrity so you can't jump Rel he goes
around
cut
behind there's the
thr he's on a different
track
okay
try all
right when when I come down
here
right it's it's doing a dual purpose
because the x is actually a spiraling
cross okay and so you could turn them
like this you see here where I left them
but his head the front of his lever is
very high which makes for me to get the
Topsy tvia effect this part of his lever
has to go high as well it's not
impossible but it's not tactically sound
so when you lower that leg that hand
eventually you're going to pin this leg
which is what you want because you don't
want him stepping back with you like in
La
Land you L want to pin that leg so he
has to come around with the other leg
you want
that so I have to go low enough to pin
that leg eventually so he steps around
but the lower the front part of the
lever the less I have to lift the back
part of the lever to create the Topsy
turby effect so the higher he is it's
very hard to get that to go over the top
the lower it is the easier it is to
project that
over so don't get lazy and not use your
legs you're like no that's all I get
that's a head a high
head hold lower it way down
there lower the head the smaller Co you
can use boom bo okay let's
go
um your your power band is in in
here
okay in
here you start going
out and you're going to turn your
hips okay so I'm trying to get some
power bound out here it doesn't work it
actually the the oppositional energy
takes you off base okay this is why like
when you see people that do Cy hole
and they're going to rotate their
hips
they got to move their
feet okay in some way or
another come around
here you
see there that there's no power out
there it starts to negatively affect
your base okay especially uh when you're
working your internals you you you're
not turning your waist because you're
going to come you're going to squeeze
the tanden okay you you only have your
qua you only have your
qua
so sometimes as you're doing this
technique you want to
see a hip thrust this way like an
OTE
or sometimes you want to see a hip
rotation this way
but this technique like all these
lateral outward lateral techniques they
throw across my
Center I don't turn my
Center
okay so you're going to look for that as
we do this
now can you see
it I throw across my
sent here
now if you're thinking straight lines
usually what the straight line people do
is they're going to crowd this guy here
get try to get
him look look what where his head is on
the normal Thro it's right there but to
get my hips Square he has to go
there you see that now you start pulling
you can also run into
you just get
there
okay when I start to bring him this way
and I want him to go where my hips can
load him straight do you
see and just try to come into me into me
this way try to come into me no just a
little we'll move to the next Degree
come into me no now I start going past
that come into
me that's what you guys are
experiencing across
your if you pay
attention it's cou
h
okay cross
my okay there's some rules when you use
the qua and and you're uh running the
internals is your feet okay so my
feet this what is now going to be the
back foot cannot be out because the quaw
can't turn into it the knee is going to
get strained okay so the the maximum the
back foot can turn is 90° to the angle
of attack this my angle of attack I can
be 90° to it
okay so even here no it's going the
other way it's fighting your movement
and now you're heel weighted okay so if
I just relax your after a while with no
micro flexion you'll see I'll lose my
balance there which means I'm not
midfoot so I'm not properly ground
vectoring so I don't have
Co so you have to watch that it's not a
waist
turn it's just it turns with my clo you
see
[Music]
okay so pay attention to what's going to
become my back foot turns turn
Okay boom boom it's going to turn but
it's not going to turn like this and nor
both feet going to turn and it's not
going to be my waist that turns the
pelvis
turns if he stands
up walk over here let me manipulate here
you
see it's it's any any entering stance
you have is just in a different place so
I'm not in a horse Dan
either I'm not
5050 there energy goes here as the qual
turns weight's going to shift to the
front foot oh but I'm not going to keep
doing that okay try it
again there's a couple other
things okay so uh don't let me cut your
hand
down you see how easy it is okay um when
you turn his body it's not because you
are pulling his arm I don't I don't want
to use that his
fingers right there leave your fingers
there dude leave them there they're here
leave them there I'm not using a ledge
here to pull
him that's where his grip is I'm not
using that what this does as I
step is it brings
here you
see and as I use I use these two
together go back
it's not that I go here keep me R please
and not I go here and I C that head he
already did the turn do you see
that you're you you do have some
external engines that you're using do
you
see one this is to touch to touch and
then I have a new adhesion point which
works together okay
so that I don't have to do this kind of
stuff you see because he can come into
me now
again come into me you see this is an
adhesion not a pull an adhesion moves
him hand your hand has to be ready it's
you're you're not your hand's not ready
early enough it's ready I go to touch
then we move together
boom when you
adhere don't adhere on the turn your
seed I'm exaggerating that there's a
dual adhesion going on go
back he's going to try to press
up you see just like any Ura technique
the guy's going to get up when he gets
up I bring it around bring the energy
around and as I bring it around just
like any Ura technique I bring it around
and
down do you see you feel that
so you can because CQ and ik are
redundant systems you can do it without
the C just keep lowering the iion so
let's try
that take the X out we're working one
line of the X go okay what what I'm
showing in these last few segments is
taking out the inertial engines which is
huge okay
I don't do I CQ like you know in some of
the Chinese internal drill
developments they don't use the inertia
because they're trying to see your skill
without it okay no no not in iido we
going to use those inertial engines and
pair them with the internal engines okay
so when I come around on his head
there's going to be centrifugal energy
you see and it's not acting equ equally
across the length of his body as I pull
the head the lower heart part of his
body has more centrifugal energy going
out do you do you got that
okay so as as I come here and I do this
part he'll roll I because that's
centrifugal energy on that same X
Vector got it I just am now cing on that
X Vector so when you're doing when we're
going to take away the
Coan it shouldn't be that I have to do
something like that okay he should
just
be having those inertial cut across the
same C line that hip will make him go
out okay try it again what what what
however he'll be in the rolling
geometry got it but we're not
doing the base deconstruction that's why
you CQ okay all right let's see but this
will give us our iy hand go once you're
doing that with your I hand then this is
easy there's less work for it to
do
[Music]
watch how low his head is watch when he
turns
[Music]
around okay put it together